empty your mind be formless shapeless
like water now you put water into a cup
it becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you put in
a teapot it becomes the teapot now water
can flow or it can crash
he water wisely
his concepts yeah he's just so deep so
deep I mean the things martial arts draw
from today he came up with a lot of nice
that I thought where do you come up with
this stuff
Bruce Lee is the man Bruce Lee is the
reason why most these guys are dermis
martial arts I mean he's the first guy
that actually got to be you know thought
of as the baddest team in the world you
ask any fighter out there growing up who
their inspiration was everybody says
Bruce Lee when you're fighting is Bruce
Lee we want to make sure you feel that
speed that power that agility that he
was known for we'll make sure that when
you're controlling Bruce Lee inside the
Octagon you feel like the Dragon you
know the Gracie's were founding fathers
of the actual UFC but I think the sport
of mixed martial arts was started by
Bruce Lee Bruce Lee's movies Bruce Lee's
philosophies just Bruce Lee's image
alone is very powerful I think he was
one of them guys that made martial arts
mainstream before the UFC before any of
this stuff was about guys wanted to be
Bruce Lee
this is a magnificent extremely powerful
vein and so on that that I strive to to
be like you know it just makes you feel
powerless because no one's gonna be like
Bruce Lee no matter how much you slay or
how much you know how much you travel to
be that type of person he's just a truly
extraordinary one-of-a-kind individual
you